hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
xpsf expression system a chemically
defined
baculovirus based expression system for
enhanced protein and virus production in
sf9 cells presented by dr kenneth
thompson
r d manager cell biology at thermo
fisher scientific
i am christy jewell of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
this presentation is brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermofisher.com
the presentation you are about to see
was previously recorded
but i would like to remind you that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
dr thompson will be answering the
questions via the email address you
provided
at the time of registration now if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you may report your problem by using
the ask a question box this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would like to introduce today's
speaker dr kenneth thompson
dr thompson is the r d manager in the
life science solutions group at thermo
fisher scientific
in frederick maryland dr thompson leads
a team of scientists
focused on developing new products for
cell biology applications
including vaculovirus based insect
systems for protein
expression and virus production
dr thompson received his phd in
molecular and cellular biology
and bs and biological sciences from the
university of maryland
baltimore county dr thompson will now
begin his presentation
so good evening everyone uh
i am going to tell you about our
most recent addition to the xp line of
protein expression products to our
xb sf system
and before i tell you about the system
so
a lot of people in here may not work
with insect cells so i thought i'd start
with
why insect cells so they're a suitable
host for expression of
intracellular proteins multimeric
proteins vlps
viral vectors and you know some proteins
that are known to be toxic to mammalian
cells
they you know this is a transducible
system so they rely on
baculovirus which has the capability of
carrying large amounts of dna payload
these proteins are produced they
have post-translational modifications
made to them
and this serves uh many purposes for you
know structural
and functional studies and the
cells are easy to grow so no co2
required they're maintained at
temperatures around 27 degrees
and then additionally there's a lower
reagent costs associated with
working with insect cells thinking about
you know you don't need a lot of plasma
dna once you make your bacterial virus
that generally
is enough to provide your needs for
multiple runs uh so this is an
established platforms uh using
insects so no known number of vaccine
and
other therapeutics are currently
produced
uh within insect cells so shown in this
table
you can see some you know list of
various
veterinarian vaccines human vaccines and
human therapeutics
i'd like to call out the last guy there
glibera
so that was the first aab approved
therapy in
in europe for treating a light
light pace deficiency disorder um
but that was made in sf9 cells
all right so just to give you guys an
overview if you haven't seen this in a
while i just wanted to go through
how this system works and how it's a
little bit different from your mammalian
transduction systems
so you start with your gene of interest
cloned into a p fastback vector
uh we then use e coli so you transform
that vector into the bacteria that
contain
the necessary cellular machinery to
mediate a transposition based event
which puts your gene of interest into
the bachmann dna genome
you then use blue white screening in e
coli
to pick clones that receive the gene of
interest
isolate the recombinant dna back mid
once you have your back mid you then
transfect that into the insect cells the
insect cells
then produce high titers of this
recombinant baculovirus
and once you have your bacular virus you
are then ready to proceed downstream
to infect your insect cells for
recombinant gene expression
all right so for the xb sf system we
um took on a systems based approach we
like to say um looking at the various
components
and so we took our sf9 cells we're able
to adapt into a chemically defined media
and what we saw here was a much higher
cell growth
this system also comes along with a
protein expression booster
in the form of an enhancer a new and
improved transfection reagent
along with the faster streamline
protocol
the one thing we didn't really change in
this system was the
upfront work that i just showed you with
the you know
the back to back cloning so the way you
make your back mid and bacteria
and all of this translates to more
protein
more consistent yields and in less time
but just so you know we do offer this
system in a
as a starter kit and so you can purchase
all the reagents that you need
ready to go consistent of our media the
cells the transfection reagent enhancer
the cloning uh the cloning kit as well
as uh
optimum which is the uh complexation
reagent for the enhancer
all right so now i'm gonna take you
through each component and tell you
about
the individual attributes that we uh
identified and and
and show you some of the performance out
of the system
starting with the media so this is the
first chemically defined
insect cell media on the market it's
yeast elate free
chemically defined aof serum free and
protein free
we currently manufacture it under cgmp
conditions
it comes ready to use no supplementation
required
and it supports all aspects of the
insect system from virus generation to
cell growth to
protein expression it's formulated to
support high density sf9 cell growth
and it shows consistent growth over
multiple passages so the graphs to the
right show the upper one
the much higher density compared to
other yeast delay containing medias
and in the solid blue line in the bottom
right graph you can see
uh over passages you know the
consistent double end times of the cells
and we offer
also offer this in a dry format which
i'll touch on in a second
all right so getting back to the cells
these are actually derived from our
original gibco sf9 cell line
we adapted them to the the chemically
defined media
and found that they uh they grew to high
cell densities with max vcds around 20
million cells per mil
they have an approximate 24 hour
doubling time and they've been optimized
for
high cell density infections so we can
actually infect these guys
all the way up to 5 million cells per ml
and they show stable
growth in expression files profiles over
20 or 20 or more passages so
bottom left graph you know low versus
high passage similar
growth performance and as well as
looking at protein titers
and the media itself shows a
very good a lot to lot variability so
this was four different lots in the
media you can see similar
group kinetics across a growth curve
over a week of culture
and also looking at the different lots
expressing gfp in this case
you can see that we see similar protein
titers so
you know reducing the lots a lot of
consistency that we've seen in other
insect medias in the past
you know this chemically defined media
really has addressed that issue
all right so as mentioned a second ago
we offer this in a dry powder format as
our
advanced granulation technology or agt
this comes auto ph auto aza auto osmo
with the fast dissolution and mis mix
time
and this agt uh compared to the liquid
format we've
been able to show that you know shows
similar growth and similar
protein expression runs so uh i'll note
that
this is currently offered not as a
catalog product it's a it's a custom
product but if you're interested
reach out to us and we can put you in
contact with the right people
all right and excitingly we actually
also brought with this a new and
improved transfection reagent uh so this
is a cationic based lipid formulation
it shows a short complexation time of
around five minutes compared to the our
old insects reagent which was 20 to 30
minutes
you can do this in a what we call a one
tube method so you no longer have to add
you know your lipid and dna to separate
tubes and then mix them together
you add your lipid to the tube add dna
straight to that tube and you're
you're ready to go uh also importantly
is there's no media change so with
sulfectin2 our old reagent um
you know you would do your transfection
and then three or four hours later after
transfection
have to come back and change your media
so we've eliminated that
annoying step and
we've also adapted this to a suspension
based transfection method
so in the past we've usually started in
a six well plate and then had to do
successive amplifications to get to
high enough viral titers for you to do
your protein expression runs
and what we have done here is with the
suspension based method is we have
eliminated the need to do that
those virus amplifications and just
doing this in a suspension flask with
our new transfection reagent you get
high quality
high tire p0 virus some more virus in
less time and we've also shown that this
is very scalable
we've actually scaled a you know p0
virus production run just doing a
transfection
all the way up to a liter with titers up
around one to two
um times ten to the ninth infectious
viral particles per ml
so thinking about that in terms of you
know
doing a protein expression run if you
have a whole leader you know you
that's pretty much enough just from a
transfection to go
into downstream bioreactors
alright so as i mentioned the suspension
based protocol
eliminates the need so the classical
system is kind of shown up top where you
produce
your p0 virus and adherent format and
then
have to amplify one to two times to make
your p1 to p2 before you get to your
protein
but with our new and improved xbsf
protocol
your you make p0 virus in a couple of
days
and you're ready to proceed to your
downstream
pro protein expression runs
so cutting from almost 20 days down you
know essentially cutting the
time the protein in half here
all right we also bring along here the
first insect
protein expression booster in the form
of an enhancer so this
enhancer is chemically defined aof
it's actually you know taking the system
altogether it's very important to
include this to get the optimal
performance
and the way it works in the protocol is
18 to 24 hours
prior to infection you add the enhancer
to your culture
the next day you infect with your virus
and you know shown on the right we
actually did a nice time course study
looking to see you know when the optimal
addition time would be to add the
enhancer and we see around
you know 18 to 24 hours as optimal you
know unfortunately we were hoping that
it would be
four to eight hours so we could squeeze
this protocol all into one day but
you know you can't have everything you
want right and this
graph on the left is just showing nicely
compared to
a traditional sf9 workflow without
enhancer you still get a protein boost
we attribute this to the biomass keeping
in mind that you can now infect these
cells
at five million cells per mil and then
you get in even further boost in titers
uh with the xbsf enhancer
so here's uh just kind of the overview
of the the protocol
for so for baculovirus generation
uh you would seed your cells at two and
a half million cells per ml
set up your transfection again that
consisting of a one tube method where
you
add your lipid the expifectamine sf
reagent
followed by the dna let that complex for
five minutes
add that directly to a suspension flask
of cells
and three or four days later you have
your p0 virus
ready to go for our protein expression
run we uh we
start cells out at 5 million cells per
ml
we call that day minus 1 and you add
that's when you add the xps
enhancer 18 to 24 hours later
you then add your p zero bachelor virus
stock
typically we recommend adding your virus
at an moi of five
and then harvest your protein uh day you
know one to four days
uh post infection
so here's a slide showing the superior
performance of this system compared to
other easterly containing medias
oops escape
there we go and so you know we got
we took a nice picture you know you can
see that you can tell that
the media's in the picture have the
isolate in them by their yellowish color
with xps
xp xbsf media and they're showing
not as yellow of a color the upper graph
again i showed you this before but
we achieved much higher vcds and this is
an example of three different proteins
that we ran
in the other comparing to the other
isolate medias and you can see
comparatively we get three to four up to
five times
uh higher protein titers with xbsf
all right uh so here is we
looked to see if we could not ex we
could express a secretive protein so we
chose secreted alkaline phosphatase
um and so compared to uh sf9 media
so a traditional system we got threefold
greater titers
we also this was this protein was his
tag so we
went down a purification run with this
using a his traffic cell column
the commodity here shows a nice clean
purification run
and then running this over sec you can
see that
you know the percent purity of the the
final product is is good for both
in the classical system and in our new
xbsf system
all right so we've heard a lot about cb2
today i figured i'd keep it in this talk
as well um so we were also able to
express this in our insect cell lines
uh so
so we did a time course study and what
we found was that you know
so most of the proteins we express with
xvsf usually day three is
you know when we collect but with
membrane proteins especially cb2 here
you know we found that 48 hours was
actually the the optimal harvest time to
get the most cb2 molecules out
with the viability of around 60 at time
of harvest
and then again you know we like to
benchmark and comparing to our
sf9 cells in sf902 media you can see
that you know in terms of looking for
total cb2 molecules we actually showed a
nice 10-fold increase in production here
all right and we've done some work
showing or some feasibility data around
production of vlp virus-like protocol
pro
virus like particles with the xpsf
system so we chose an envelope
and a non-enveloped vlp so the
chikungunya virus and human papilloma
and i think the data speaks for itself
here but you know looking at the western
or
quantitating the area quantitating the
area under the curve
you can see that for the evil using an
anti-e1 antibody for the chikungunya we
get about a five-fold increase
in expression and likewise we see about
a three-fold increase
with the non-enveloped vlp
all right so now i'm going to tell you a
little bit about the system scalability
uh so system's very scalable you know we
can
from 125 mil shake flask all the way up
to the 2 liter scale we see
pretty similar titers and not only can
we scale up but we can scale down down
to
24 deep well plates and again achieve
similar titers note that the shake
speeds for the 24 well plate are a
little bit different you got to shake
them a little bit faster
but overall we see equal uh equal
performance
with this system at all flat scales
we then scaled up even further so we did
an expression run
in a 22 liter wave bag with a 10
liter working volume we tested this for
three different proteins so gfp and fc
fusion and seep
and so looking at the blue and red bars
you can see that
you know comparatively why we did not
meet com
you know complete levels of where the
the shake flats are
we were pretty happy to be around 70 to
80 percent um
in the weight bag in terms of
performance
likewise we also scaled up into it one
of our finesse buyer reactors
uh and in this case you know looking at
this protein's expression you can see
that
you know we were actually on par with
the flask
um in this situation so we're pretty
pleased by that
all right so shift into uh another
you know showing the versatility of the
xbsf system we
you know once we launched this product
you know we designed it thinking protein
expression but we launched it and then
we got
numerous customer inquiries about has
anybody tried aav in your system
so we undertook an investigation to see
if we could accomplish that
so to do this we did a we took a dual
infection approach
uh so just reminding you that we use
baculoviruses for so for aav production
you need a rep cap vacuum virus as well
as a
itr gene of interest baculovirus our
gene of interest here will be gfp
you infect with those two bacterial
viruses and you then
make your recombinant aav particles so
work i don't have time to show you
that today but we did a bunch of does
looking for
you know optimal conditions in terms of
some seating densities mois for
what would give the best viral titers
here but what it came down to
shown in the table in the upper right is
that you know unlike
xbsf where we seed at 5 million cells
per ml for
aav production it came down to 3 million
cells per ml seeding
with an moi of 2 for each of the
bacterial viruses
all right so to the results we tested
xps system production for both for two
serotypes serotype two and six
with and without enhancer so nicely you
can see
just looking at the genome titers we
were on par with what's reported in
terms of what people get
in terms of vector genome tighter you
know in the range of 10 to the 10th to
10 to the 11th
vector genomes per ml and then what we
really like to see is that you know not
only does our chemical enhancer boost
protein expression
but here it's also boosting our aav
titers as well
so so multi-um multi-functional there
and then for comparison's sake we uh
compared this also to sf9 cells and
sf902 media
following a published protocol and
you can see that you know both xbsf and
sf902
produce high viral titers for for both
stereotypes
so we next asked if we could you know
scale up the aav
similar to protein expression so shown
in the upper right
you see similar growth kinetics through
the expression runs for
the finesse three liter bioreactor
compared to shake flask
and on the bottom left are the aav
genome titers
so we were the red bars are with the
finesse and you can see that
while we weren't excuse me quite similar
to where the shake flash were we're
still around 70 to 80 percent
of those aav titers um which is still
pretty good
and then significantly if you take these
aav particles that you get out of the
insect cells and you put them on hd 1080
indicator cells you show good
functionality that you're
not only producing particles but this
virus is also infectious
and then finally i'll end here today
showing you some nice work we did as
as a team um you know this was a lot of
collaborations that that helped out with
this work
so we took a 1.2 liter uh
culture run of of aav6
we used our porous capture select aav
affinity resin
and the upper you know chromatogram
there shows the actitrace
and you can see the very nice strong
elution peak of the aav particles coming
off the column
the kamasi gel on the bottom left shows
very pure aav
particles so vp one two and three are
the three
proteins that make up the outer shell of
the baryon
and then quantitating uh the total
genome containing particles so we load
it onto the column
uh there yeah so we'll be loaded onto
the column and what we eluded we
actually got about a 60
recovery in doing the math that comes
out to be about
almost two e13 genome particles
just from one liter of culture and you
know that's
pretty much on par with what people see
in in the industry right now they look
for
you know from a 2000 liter bioreactor
run they expect to get about 10 to the
16th
to 10 of the 17 total particles so we're
in that ballpark so we're happy about
that
and then we also took some images uh
did some electron microscopy on the
eluded particles you can see that you
know we're really pleased with this
significantly that
you know there's actually majority of
them look full as contain
as you know as opposed to empty and
particles that were eluded again on the
ht 1080 indicator cells
show activity based on their gfp
fluorescence
all right i will in there
of course thank you all my members of
the team uh
in r d as well as program and product
management and our
marketing staff who are sitting back
there sapner reed thank you for all your
help
a big thank you goes out to dr kenneth
thompson for his excellent presentation
now if you do have any questions you
would like to ask dr thompson
please type them in the ask a question
box on the far left of your screen
dr thompson will be answering the
questions via the email address you
provided
at the time of registration we would
also like to thank
lab routes and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
you